ان جل ما قاومنا ونقاوم به عدوان الصهاينه
هو من صنع كتائب
القسام اسبوع توالت فيه الخيبات على
اسرائيل خسائر بشريه فادحه تشدد الخناق
على حكومه نتنياهو واخفاق في فتح ثغرات
امام فصائل مسلحه عنيده في غزه انسحاب
وتراجع واستعراض تاريخي لجرائم الاحتلال
امام اعلى هيئه قضائيه في
[موسيقى]
العالم ظهر المتحدث العسكري باسم القسام
ابو عبيده بالصوت والصوره لاول مره منذ
ال3 من نوفمبر الماضي واكد ان القسام ضربت
الف اليه عسكريه اسرائيليه منذ بدء
العدوان وهذه
الصناعات لم تكن لتجدي نفعا امام الترسانه
الامريكيه الهائله القذره
لولا الصناعه الاهم التي نمتلكها وهي
صناعه الانسان المقاتل ظهور تزامن مع نشر
تقديرات عسكريه اسرائيليه بان معظم مقاتلي
حماس وقادتها في غزه على قيد الحياه بعد
100 يوم من الحرب وفي وقت تتسع فيه اصداء
الخلافات داخل تل ابيب في جدوى حرب سحبت
قوات الاحتلال الفرقه 36 من قطاع غزه
لتبقى في القطاع ثلاث فرق هي 99
و162
و98 انسحاب انتقده وزير الامن القومي
الاسرائيلي اتمار بن غفير ووصفه بالخطا
الفادح والخطير لكن الاحصاءات الصادره
خلال هذا الاسبوع عن اعداد القتلى والجرحى
في صفوف الجيش الاسرائيلي تظهر حجم الضغوط
على حكومه نتنياهو الذي تراجعت نسبه
تاييده الى
29% وفق اخر الاستطلاعات اذا ارتفع عدد
القتلى الى
525 منذ السابع من اكتوبر في حين تقول
المقاومه الفلسطينيه ان عدد قتلى الجيش
الاسرائيلي اكبر من المعلن بكثير شنم ب
خونس
و
ر مخ بم
مصا حدثت عن 100 ال طلب للمساعده النفسيه
باسرائيل خلال الحرب وبلغ عدد الصواريخ
التي سقطت على الاراضي المحتله 11000
صاروخ خلال 100 يوم منها 9000 صاروخ اطلقت
من غزه وفي المقابل قصف الاحتلال 3 ال
موقع في القطاع و
3400 في لبنان ووسط ذهول امريكي اسرائيلي
من انفاق حماس في غزه بحسب وصف صحيفه
نيويورك تايمز قال منسق الاتصالات
الاستراتيجيه لمجلس الامن القومي في البيت
الابيض جون كيربي ان اسرائيل انتقلت حاليا
الى مرحله اقل حده في عملياتها العسكريه
بقطاع غزه وتصاعدت هذا الاسبوع وتيره
المجازر في غزه مع اتساع رقعه القصف لتشمل
كل انحاء القطاع خلال سبعه ايام استشهد 11
شخص وفق بيانات وزاره الصحه في غزه ليرتفع
العدد الاجمالي الى اكثر من
24500 شهيد وما تزال مئات الجثث مدفونه
تحت الركام وفي الطرقات ولا تستطيع فرق
الاسعاف والدفاع المدني الوصول اليها في
ظل استمرار القصف ودقت وزاره الصحه ناقوس
الخطر من انتشار التهاب الكبد الوبائي من
نوع اي نتيجه الاقتضاب وتدني مستويات
النظافه في اماكن النزوح بالقطاع وبعد ما
عايش 100 يوم من الحرب واثارها القاسيه
وصل الى الى العاصمه القطريه الدوحه
الزميل وائل الدحدوح مراسل الجزيره في
قطاع غزه لتلقي العلاج من اصابته بغاره
اسرائيليه اواخر الشهر الماضي دوليا راقب
العالم في بث مباشر لساعات استعراضا وصف
بالتاريخي لممارسات اسرائيل في غزه في اول
جلسه لمحكمه العدل الدوليه في لاهاي ضمن
الدعوه التي رفعتها جنوب افريقيا على
اسرائيل وتتهمها بارتكاب اباده جماعيه
وشهد هذا الاسبوع ايضا تصعيدا غربيا في
اليمن بعد شن الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا
غارات جويه على مواقع تابعه لجماعه انصار
الله
الحوثيين تصعيد اقبه بايام اعاده واشنطن
تصنيف جماعه الحوثي في اليمن منظمه
ارهابيه ع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تستخدم هذا
التصنيف كبتز لكل من يخالف توجهاتها ويقف
معارضا لسياساتها لكن مستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي جيك سلفن اكد ان كان التراجع عن
هذا القرار اذا اوقفت الجماعه هجماتها في
البحر
الاحمر هذا هو خيارنا
قدرنا ويجب ان نرضى به مهما
كان
ه